[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo ante la situación de kobe 19
ahora trabajamos desde casa un nuevo
decreto en cuba' que regula el uso de
las redes sociales y lo que los
ciudadanos pueden publicar despierta
preocupaciones dentro y fuera de la isla
por sus implicaciones directas a la
libertad de expresión el decreto ley 35
castiga contenido subversivo y lo que
las autoridades califican como noticias
falsas o que inciten a las
manifestaciones mientras que el gobierno
asegura que esta normativa busca
combatir el ciber terrorismo los cubanos
denuncian que este tipo de restricciones
no son nuevas y que esta ley no es más
que la oficialización de la censura que
ya se venía aplicando en la isla desde
que se amplió el uso del internet
empezamos
y entender ha tenido una lenta expansión
en cuba' hace una década su uso libre
solo estaba reservado para empresas
instituciones e intelectuales y sólo
hasta 2018 el internet móvil llegó a la
isla desde entonces ha habido un
incremento en la actividad en línea pero
de manera paralela también ha aumentado
el control sobre lo que los ciudadanos
pueden hacer allí según denuncias los
cortes del servicio de internet y la
suspensión selectiva del servicio
telefónico activistas y opositores es
cada vez más frecuente en el país sobre
todo cuando esta tecnología se usa para
disentir ejemplo de ello fue el apagón
digital que se produjo después de las
masivas protestas antigubernamentales
del 11 de julio las más grandes desde
1994 durante el llamado maleconazo y que
lograron organizarse a través de las
redes sociales estas plataformas se han
convertido en herramientas fundamentales
para la organización ciudadana y ahora
una nueva normativa que plantea
restringir aún más su uso preocupa a los
internautas
se trata del decreto-ley 35 que fue dado
a conocer un mes después de las
protestas este establece el marco
regulatorio de las telecomunicaciones en
cuba y genera preocupación por una serie
de polémicas medidas por ejemplo se
considera como una acción altamente
peligrosa la divulgación de noticias
falsas mensajes ofensivos y de formación
con impacto en el prestigio del país
expertos señalan que la ambigua
definición de estos términos le da pie
al gobierno para aplicar la ley de
manera selectiva castigando cualquier
comentario que no sea de su agrado
también se le atribuye un alto nivel de
peligrosidad a la difusión de contenidos
que atentan contra los preceptos
constitucionales sociales y económicos
del estado inciten a movilizaciones u
otros actos que alteren el orden público
en resumen estaría limitando el derecho
a los ciudadanos a convocar a
manifestaciones
en conjunto con estas normas el artículo
69 de la ley de la permiso a los
operadores y proveedores de internet en
este caso a la empresa estatal etecsa
que es el único proveedor de interrumpir
el servicio si llegan a presentarse los
casos que acabamos de describir
el gobierno cubano culpa al embargo
estadounidense de la falta de acceso
libre a internet para el presidente
miguel díaz canel las campañas que se
mueven en redes sociales en contra de su
gobierno no son más que terrorismo
mediático y según dice el decreto-ley 35
está destinado a combatirlo como las
redes sociales un mecanismo de
dominación colonial es un instrumento de
colonizar colonización que lo que
pretende que la gente nieguen su
identidad no son red no son redes
sociales son redes antisociales son
redes digitales pero es lo que hacen es
antisocial
la comunidad no crea amistad no crea
relaciones humanas genera odio manipula
los sentimientos tergiversa la realidad
de construyen realidad virtual pero los
internautas y las organizaciones
defensoras de derechos humanos califican
esta normativa como ley mordaza que
busca acallar las voces críticas y
denuncian que éste no es más que la
legalización de medidas que ya se venían
tomando en la isla así nos lo explica el
activista cubano jorge castro tal no es
con el decreto 35 que se van a limitar
la expresión de lo cubano en la red
social eso había estaba pasando desde el
mismo punto en el mismo inicio en que
las redes sociales llegaron a la
población
el decreto 35 más del inicio de la
censura el decreto 35 en la
oficialización de la censura y
obviamente las personas que se expresan
en cuba en las redes sociales tienen un
sinnúmero de consecuencias de las tantas
que te estoy explicando lo pueden
expulsar de las universidades de los
centros laborales sufren acoso lo hemos
visto con los influencia cubanos dentro
de la digna muchos fueron interrogados
muchos fueron acostados
con la teoría del estado incluso algunos
de ellos han sido silenciados
pero cubano es el único país con este
tipo de legislaciones destinadas a
combatir las noticias falsas y que
terminaron siendo criticadas por la
ambigüedad de sus conceptos en américa
latina y el caribe su vecino puerto rico
aprobó el año pasado una ley que
criminaliza el compartir información que
el gobierno considere falsa ya sea a
través de cualquier red social o medio
de comunicación masivo y que tenga la
intención de crear pánico confusión o
histeria colectiva la ley fue aprobada
en medio de los reportes sobre la crisis
sanitaria provocada por el cob y 19 y
preocupa que no pueda informarse
libremente acerca de la pandemia el
mismo año nicaragua aprobó la llamada
ley especial de ciberdelitos que castiga
la propagación de lo que se considere
como noticias falsas y o tergiversadas y
que fomentan alarma terror y zozobra
entre las personas esto afecta tanto
medios de comunicación críticos con el
gobierno como a ciudadanos que usan sus
redes sociales para hacer denuncias
mientras que en venezuela se aprobó en
2017 la llamada ley contra el odio la
legislación establece sanciones de hasta
20 años de privación de la libertad para
quienes inciten al odio oa la violencia
en radio televisiones redes sociales
pero no hay claridad sobre la definición
del odio por lo que podría dársele una
amplia y conveniente interpretación con
el objetivo de sortear este tipo de
restricciones en la isla de eeuu trabaja
buscando formas de proveer internet a
los cubanos se habla de globos wifi como
el que se usó hace 4 años en puerto rico
tras la devastación provocada por el
huracán maría oa través de satélites y
puntos de acceso en alta mar pero aún
existen dudas sobre su implementación
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
tras 24 punto com